jay what's up brother how we doing
what's up
brother thank you so much for all you're
doing i love the show
man i am grateful for you number one
thanks for letting me know that
um sometimes i just talk to folks on the
radio and then james and kelly put this
on the internet and i really don't
understand how that works and so i
appreciate hearing from real people
thanks man
so how can i help you this morning all
right man so here's the deal i'm
sad or what i'm calling about a seasonal
effective disorder i come up against
this
every year yeah and kind of my
question to you is a two-part question
first of all
why is it happening is there something i
need uh to kind of fix
or or review and then further
what can i do about some of the the
effects of seasonal affective disorder
so i'm calling for myself obviously and
also
extended family and friends that i know
suffer with this so
just kind of looking to get your insight
into any help would be appreciated
to kind of outline a scenario
calling from the northeast the great
lakes region
it's october right now the leaves are
beautiful but
seasons come seasons go and we're about
to
enter winter that's right right now
we're losing we're losing light
it's getting cool it's getting
depressing winter's right around the
corner
and it seems like year in and year out
this is a four to five month
cycle so just kind of reaching out i
want to get a jump on this
and get your insight all right brother i
love it
and kelly tipped me off that we were
gonna have
a discussion about seasonal affective
disorder
um and so number one i'm grateful for
your call number two
i've got a personal experience here so
as as i run my mouth too much and i've
tried to back off on this i got all of
your cards and letters from everybody
listening that i talk too much about
texas i'm trying not to mention it so
much
but when i moved here from texas i was
about 30 or 45 minutes from the new
mexico border
and which is another time zone right
it's the other time zone
and then i moved to nashville which is
about 30 or 45 minutes from
i think it's the eastern time zone and
man
my first winter here i was completely
caught off guard
it was getting dark at 4 30. i found
myself
winding up for bed at 6 45 in the
evening it was pitch black outside
i was things weren't funny anymore my
food tasted bland
it was it caught me off guard and i
called some buddies who had moved from
you know the south from the the from
texas from arizona and who had moved
east who'd moved north and they were all
like oh brother that's what that is and
i'd heard about it i'd read about it i'd
never experienced it but it was like
somebody laid a blanket over me right
and it occurred to me about february or
march
that that was the longest i'd ever gone
in my life without sunlight
and that was the like since i was a
little since i was born i'd always lived
in a place with lots of sun
and it was a it made a major impact on
me so i dug into it a little bit
and i will walk through with you some of
the nerd things i do
the super nerds call them hacks i don't
like using that word but some things
that i do
is some of it brother may be
psychosomatic meaning i mean
my brain may be playing tricks on me
saying it helps and it really doesn't
but it's working for me
and as i'm gearing up for that season i
know ohio is similar to nashville it
just feels like they lay this gray
blanket of clouds over us right
and it just lays there and gets lower
and lower
the weather's beautiful the scenery is
beautiful this morning on the way to
work there were deer and turkey out
just eating it it looked all beautiful
but man there's just got that blanket
laying over us right
so exactly um it is super real seasonal
defective
seasonal affective disorder affects
millions of people
um every year some folks have mild form
some have
major depressive responses the further
we live for the from the equator the
more
it it leans on us right so they say more
sad right
and then you're going to throw in this
year i'm just prepping for it
this year we're going to have i don't
know if you've heard i don't know if
they've talked about this in ohio but we
have an election coming up in a few days
and um you guys have may have missed um
the coronavirus has been a thing
for the last nine months right so we're
on tragedy on top of tragedy on top of
tragedy right
and so it's gonna i'm expecting it to be
heavier this year
and so why do we feel it um some say
that it is
the sunlight is the is the number one
thing we are vitamin d
creatures we've got to have vitamin d
we've got to have sunlight and it
regulates our melatonin release it
regulates our
wake and sleep cycles and when those
things get compressed
our bodies just shut down they just slow
down it's winter right the same as the
as the grass turns brown right the trees
the leaves fall off the trees they're
not dead but they just go dormant for a
while and our bodies do something very
similar
um and so sunlight helps stimulate
melatonin it helps simulate
vitamin d a whole cascade of chemical
systems right and without that stuff
vitamin d
boost serotonin all i don't be a super
nerd here but it all has
chemical responses and also we stop
going out
we stop being around other people we
stop
um meeting we just go to bed it's early
and it's dark and let's just call it
let's just watch a little more netflix
get under the covers a little further
um some have said we stopped being
intimate with our
with our partners we stopped right so
you back off sex
you start eating a little bit worse you
start sleeping a little bit more
and that's just signals to your body to
depress stuff right to lay low
so here's a couple of things that i do
personally actually i'll walk through
the big ones and then i'll tell you a
couple of the nerd things that i do
here's some highly intentional stuff we
can do number one in
these aren't going to be shockers or
anything
but go outside and enjoy nature
even if it's freezing make yourself
bundle up and go outside as often as you
can
um i i
am a big believer and there's no bad
weather there's just wrong clothes
and so if it's freezing and it's snowing
and it's
raining me and my kids are playing
outside and
we are running around being silly and it
may be so
cold that we are chitter chattering and
but we're going outside
we're going to continue to be connected
with one another and we're gonna
continue to go outside
um even if it's just 15 minutes 10
minutes 15 minutes go outside right
the second thing is is i this is gonna
this is
me being vulnerable here with with the
you and the 17 listeners of this podcast
i put um human connection on my calendar
i am a person who retreats by nature and
so i have to have intentional
conversations i have to intentionally
see
people it's going to be challenging in
the winter this year because i've been
able to
this summer and this fall we have a lot
of outdoor conversations we have people
over but we eat out on the front porch
in the backyard
i'm gonna have to be hyper intentional
in a season of covid
in a season of winter being with other
people you
gotta see your friends you gotta see
your friends you gotta see your friends
be hyper intentional even if you have to
schedule it um
make sure that you are still being
intimate make sure you are still holding
hands make sure as you start every
morning if
you've got a pet you've got a
you know a significant other in the bed
next to you hold their hand
hug that dog right touch your bare feet
to their bare feet make sure you're
getting skin to skin contact
and you're feeling somebody else's
heartbeat do everything you can in your
power to eat well
sleep a lot and exercise not too much
not too little but man once you once i
get the sugar rush of halloween usually
i can hold on till halloween
jay and then i get on a gummy candy
binge
and i really don't recover until january
till new year's
i just lose it man and then my wife
stays inside and she starts baking and
she's an extraordinary cook now my son's
a
chef now and he's baking everything my
daughter and i just mainline sugar it
just
goes down a rabbit hole so it's making
highly intentional choices about what
i'm eating and
then have things to to look forward to
one of the things depression does to us
even seasonally is it makes us our
bodies feel like our minds feel like
this is going to be this way forever
and so plan something for early march
plan something for when the when this
when the
like a vacation get out of town even a
small camping trip
but put some things on the calendar that
we can look forward to now here's a
couple of
nerd things and i've hinted at this a
little bit
for the last decade i've lived up to my
eyeballs
in the research literature with the
outer banks of what i would call
woo-woo stuff and with just
basic just physiology and human anatomy
here's a couple of things that i double
down on now
in the winter months starting now is a
highly regimented no questions asked
i cannot skip it and this is a personal
commitment
cannot skip a morning routine that
involves
meditation that involves silence that
involves my feet
on bare ground this is grounding that's
super woo-woo but i think i
think the science supports it but it's 5
or 10 or 15 minutes with my feet on bare
ground
it is feeling the seasons and it is an
exercise program that no matter what's
coming
um i'm gonna exercise even if i get
halfway through my prog my workout that
morning i'm gonna do something
i also am a big weimhof guy
w-i-m-h-o-f we'll link to him in the
show notes he is all about
cold thermogenesis ice baths and these
are not ice baths like athletes take
after a hard workout
this is ice baths as a way of regulating
your body
and i won't get into the science here
but i take i have a
tub that i bought from a a outdoor farm
supply store
and it's a metal tub that i fill with
water and sits outside in the winter
and it usually has ice in it floating in
it or it's frozen over
and i get in there from three to six to
ten minutes sometimes
every morning every morning sometimes in
the evening and it is unbearable and it
is brutal and it is beautiful
um and so it is called cold
thermogenesis weimhoff he's awesome
the last thing here um i'll talk through
this for the podcast but i will
show it for the youtube um
i don't get paid for any of these things
thorn and keon those are the two
supplement companies that i trust
i overdo it probably on vitamin d k2
i've got it here this is what i take
regularly i take a lot of it
the research on vitamin d and coven the
research on vitamin d
and seasonal defective disorder and
hormone regulation and um
all the different biomechanical
mechanism biomechanisms
vitamin d regulates a lot and so does k2
and so does magnesium so i take a lot of
that stuff
and here's one of my nerd gadgets that i
love it's called the human charger
by valky uh it's it's obnoxiously
expensive
but you put it in your ears and it
actually
shines a bright light into your ear it's
an led light when i show friends and
family they roll their eyes and say
that money would have been better if you
had set it on fire i love this thing i
think it works i use it every morning on
the way to work
um it cycles through two or three it's
called the human charger you can look it
up on the internet we'll link to in the
show notes i love that thing too
but it's about bright lights and so when
you wake up in the morning
turning this bright of lights on as you
can i've heard the investments in the
the sad bulbs they call them are worth
it they're good
and so um being intentional about making
sure you're around a lot of bright light
the right kind of light
and letting your natural biorhythms
work even when the sun is down here's
one final thing
you've heard me say this on the podcast
often and i'll continue to say it
we try as if people for the last hundred
years
to power through nature we have tried to
hit the gas
and turbo charge and jet propulse our
way
as though nature didn't know what she
was doing
we've tried to to
i mean i don't want to get into it here
we've tried to out
farm mother nature by just beating the
soil to death we've tried to
out um outgrow animals
beyond mother nature we've just lost our
minds we thought we won
and mother nature is proving as she
always does that she
knows what she's doing that she's in
control and there's an ebb and flow to
the world
one of the things we can do in the
winter months
is just slow down just slow down
and that's hard for us right but we have
to remember that up until about 60 years
ago you couldn't get apples in the
grocery store
in february because it was winter and
apples weren't growing
and we could not just get sunshine all
the time
and there was a natural pulse and a
natural rhythm to life
and so i want to encourage everybody to
take care of yourself do these things
right we got to keep showing up for work
i've got to keep showing up to the
podcast
i've got to keep doing the things i've
got to do to keep food on my table
and also listen to the rhythms
of nature listen to the rhythms of your
body
and it's okay to sleep a little bit more
it's okay to get a little more pensive
it's okay to write a little bit more in
your journal
or to add five or six things to your
gratitude journal every morning
it's okay to read a little bit more it's
okay to slow down
and so i don't want us to spend so much
energy fighting
the natural systems but at the same time
there are some cool things we can do to
lift this up